sad news for Dancing with the Stars host  Tom Bergeron the TV personality is  missing Monday show to be with his sick  father Tom tweeted the sad news with a  black and white childhood photo with his  dad he captioned the sweet pic i'll miss  tomorrow's DWTS to be at my dad's  bedside he's given me a lifetime of  support time to return the favor  season 19 champ Alfonso Ribeiro will  take over hosting duties Monday night  this isn't the first time we've heard of  the former Fresh Prince of bel-air star  filling in for Bergeron in May he took  over as host of America's Funniest Home  Videos I'm really excited I think I  think people are going to you know love  it like they always have and love it  maybe just a bit more with the new  updated version